hi mystery recapt here today I'm going
to explain an American coming-of-age
Comedy drama film called the half of it
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the film revolves around a smart and
introverted girl named Ellie Chu who
lives in the remote town of Squamish
with her widow or father she lives by
the train tracks as her father works as
a train master and a signal man however
the budget is always tight so Ellie
spends her days making extra money by
writing homework papers for her fellow
students at high school she also often
gets picked on by the popular kids when
riding her bike to and from school one
day her English teacher finds out that
she has been writing for the other
classmates but instead of scolding Ellie
the teacher thanks her for helping the
class achieve good grades that does make
the teacher look good she then
encourages Ellie to apply to the
prestigious Grinnell College as she
recognizes her potential however despite
being unhappy in Squamish Ali plans to
stay because she does not want to leave
her father all alone later during music
class we are introduced to one Aster
Flores who is dating the popular and
wealthiest kid in town Craig Carson here
it is clear that Ellie has some sort of
Attraction towards Aster but she puts it
off and focuses on playing the piano on
the way back from school she is
approached by a football player named
Paul munsky from her school Paul is an
inarticulate and weird individual who
mysteriously exists
but no one knows much about him he wants
Ellie to help him write a love letter to
his Crush asked her in return he is
ready to pay double her normal charges
however Ellie declines saying that these
types of letters should be written by
oneself deep down she doesn't want
anyone to propose to Astor She's Mine
munsky you but the next day after
learning that her home's electricity
Supply will be cut off if they don't
make a minimum payment of fifty dollars
Ellie agrees to write the love letter in
the day the two sit down together and
she reads his sample she finds it to be
very awkward as Paul goes off topic too
many times Ali addresses these problems
with him but Paul retaliates stating
that she wouldn't know as she has never
been in love this pisses Ellie off and
she storms away but not before promising
to write the best love letter Paul has
ever seen Romeo Where Art Thou I'm in
the same evening at home Ellie and her
father watch a movie together
simultaneously she is trying to write
the love letter but doesn't get any
ideas when nothing comes to mind she
uses a line from the movie there watch
teaching the following day Paul gets the
letter and without giving it a good read
he places it inside Astor's Locker she
does reply a few days later but not in
the way Paul had hoped Esther taunts him
for plagiarizing from a movie revealing
that she too is an Avid Reader and movie
Watcher in response Ellie writes that
she often uses other people's quotes to
describe how she feels about the world
if she understood what love was she
would quote herself pastor resonates
with her saying that life can be very
hard sometimes in this way the two begin
a heartfelt correspondence through
letters the only catch being that Astor
believes she is communicating with Paul
she often feels alone and left out
because trig and her friends think she
is boring however after unknowingly
conversing with Ellie through letters
and texts she begins to feel understood
and accepted one day Paul and Aster are
set on a date while Ellie listens in on
their conversation as expected their
date is a disaster as Paul is unable to
communicate with her like in the text
messages and letters the next day Ellie
meets him and expresses that they should
stop trying now she believes that the
more they lie and deceive after the more
difficult it will become to convince her
however when Paul defends Ellie from
some bullies on the way back home she
changes her mind and decides to help him
again this time she intends to use a
different approach over the course of
the next few weeks Ellie teaches Paul
about art literature and other things
that interest during this time the two
get to bond and know a lot about each
other they also open up about their
family struggles it turns out that
Paul's family has been in the sausage
industry for as long as he can remember
and they want him to continue with the
business mom dad is sausage industry a
euphemism however he finds it very
boring and wants to try something
different currently he is working on a
new dish called Taco sausage which he
thinks will be a revolutionary food item
he has even mailed various food critics
about his idea but so far none of them
have responded as for Ellie her parents
emigrated from China a long time ago her
mother died when she was young while her
father who is a PhD in engineering isn't
able to find the appropriate job because
of his accent now he is forced to work
as a train station master and Signal man
could be worse a lot of guys would give
their left nut to be called train Master
as the two narrate their stories they
gradually become connected to one
another they even spy on Aster to get a
good grip on the things she likes doing
luckily the hard work pays off and Paul
is eventually invited for a second date
however when the big moment arrives he
is nervous and still has trouble
conversing with Astor meanwhile Ellie
observes their date from outside a
window seeing the plan go sideways she
messages asked her pretending to be Paul
and saves the evening Paul doesn't have
a clue what's going on so he simply acts
as if he is texting under the table
after a while when Astor appears Charmed
he suddenly expresses his feelings for
her the two then finally start talking
while Ellie sees them and gets upset
eventually leaving the place on her bike
the next day Ellie has chosen to play
the piano in the high school recital so
she shops for some clothes for the event
and Paul accompanies her he tells her
about his date with faster last night
revealing that he kissed her but this
only upsets Ellie she begins
contemplating her decision to assist him
on the day of the program during a rock
and roll performance Ellie's bullies
secretly meddle with the piano shortly
after she steps onto the stage and
proceeds to play but to her horror some
of the keys in the piano are broken
Ellie tries to improvise and come up
with a song but it sounds so bad that
the audience starts making fun of her
meanwhile Paul who is watching
everything unfold from backstage finds
out that it was the bullies who broke
the piano so he quickly passes her a
guitar and tells her to play a song this
is because Ellie once mentioned that her
favorite instrument is the guitar not
the piano hesitantly she starts playing
and after a while she gets into the
groove Ellie even sings a beautiful song
that she had written herself after her
performance the audience showers her
with a loud Applause making her relieved
the same evening Paul takes Ellie to the
senior recital party where she is
greeted by everyone and they all treat
her like a friend unable to contain her
happiness Ellie gets heavily and
intoxicated it almost passes out so Paul
takes her to his home after he lays her
down to sleep Paul goes through her bag
and finds several letters they have been
addressed to popular food critics
presumably about his sausage Creations
this makes Paul very happy and he starts
liking her even more unfortunately the
next morning Aster arrives there and
finds Ellie in Paul's bedroom the two
have an awkward conversation where Ellie
explains that she was simply passing by
to drop some books off she also reveals
that Paul is head over heels in love
with Aster which finally relieves the
latter as the two girls continue talking
they bond over their shared interest in
art and literature so they decide to
spend the day together anyone else feel
like this is headed for a threesome at
first Ellie takes Astor near the train
tracks and demonstrates her father's job
as a signal man don't be humble Ally
he's a train Master damn it then they
hop into Aster's car and reach a hidden
hot spring in a secluded Forest once
there Astor undresses and jumps into the
spring while Ellie is ashamed to look at
her but after a bit of convince she also
joins in and enters the water with her
shirt on the two share an intimate
conversation where Astor opens up about
her conflicting feelings for Paul She
also reveals that she heard her
boyfriend trig talking to her father
about marrying her in the evening after
Astor dropped Sally off at her home she
meets Paul while he is taking out the
trash it turns out that he has started
bonding with Ellie's dad and regularly
helps with the housework Esther asks him
if he believes in God to which he says
yes suddenly she pulls Paul in for a
kiss but after it is done neither of
them seem that thrilled Ellie Witnesses
this from her bedroom window and becomes
upset however this gives her renewed
motivation to do something in life so
she dusts off the old Grinnell college
application that she had put away the
next day Paul has his football game so
both Ellie and Astor show up to support
him however despite his kiss with Aster
the previous night he is more excited to
see Ellie he even wins the game for his
mediocre team by delivering a brilliant
performance after the game Paul
approaches Ellie and it is revealed that
he is developed feelings for her so he
takes his chance and leans in for a cast
but she brutally rejects him to make
matters worse Astor walks in on them
Ellie tries to explain the situation but
she doesn't hear any of it and storms
out angrily seeing the look in her eyes
Paul realizes that Ellie is in fact in
love with Aster he tries to warn her
that it is a sin and that she will go to
hell for it but Ellie being an atheist
could care less from then onwards
everybody is in a state of sadness Alias
filled with guilt for manipulating Aster
with her letters Astor is stuck with the
self-centered trig and Paul has left to
ponder on what to do with his life I
don't know Paul do something with
sausages later in the week Paul delivers
sausages
oh my God later in the week Paul
delivers sausages to Ellie's Helm where
he meets her father the two have a
heart-to-heart conversation about love
Paul then comes to terms with accepting
who Ellie is and to love her in a
different way one day everyone is
gathered at a church Paul is with his
family trig and Astor are together while
Ellie is on the piano to play some hymns
shortly after trig gives a short and
self-absorbed speech about how nice his
girlfriend Aster is after the speech he
shockingly proposes to Aster in front of
everyone and she hesitantly says yes
Ellie immediately jumps to her feet and
before she can confess her love the
priest abruptly cuts her off a few
seconds later the priest is also cut off
as Paul stands and gives a speech about
love he mentions that pretending is not
a part of love and that no one should
fake it seeing Paul's courage Ellie also
shares the true meaning of love using
her words from a previous letter she had
written to Astor this makes Astor
realize that she has been communicating
with Ellie through the letters and texts
all along enraged she vehemently lapse
Paul for lying to her before storming
out of the church the movie then cuts to
several weeks later where Ellie is in
the kitchen with her father they are
cooking some dumplings as Ellie is soon
leaving for Iowa she has finally been
accepted into Grinnell College however
she doesn't want to leave things
unresolved with Aster it turns out that
Astor's been keeping a low profile ever
since the church incident despite This
Ellie manages to track her down to a
restaurant where she works she then
apologizes for writing the letters
pretending to be Paul Esther responds by
saying that deep down she did probably
know the truth about it and considered
the possibility of Ellie being a lesbian
with this the two reconcile and
playfully tease each other before
leaving Ellie even kisses Astor and
tells her that she will see her in a
couple of years later Ellie prepares to
leave squahamish before she boards the
train Paul sees her off at the platform
he tells her that his sausage recipes
have received good reviews from a lot of
people and it's only a matter of time
before he gets a large contract move
over Warren Buffett Here Comes wiener
buffet buffet he also Promises to Keep
visiting her father and keep him company
finally Ellie boards the train and as it
pulls away Paul runs beside it mimicking
the old Romance movie that they had
watched together she calls him an idiot
and laughs at his silliness but as the
train gains speed and leaves Paul behind
Ellie turns around as tears run down her
face the movie ends as Ellie observes
the passengers around her as she goes
off to start a new journey in her life
move over Bezos Here Comes charitos
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching